bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on est à moins d'une semaine des
élections présidentielles et on continue
nos explorations sociologique du vote la
dernière fois on a vu le paradoxe du
votant à savoir que le comportement
parfaitement rationnel en finalité n'est
pas d'aller voter mais serait plutôt de
s'abstenir pourtant on en a pas fini
avec cette notion de rationalité parce
que justement une vision qu'on a souvent
pour se représenter l'acte de vote c'est
celle d'un électeur en fait parfaitement
rationnel qui va lire tous les
programmes qui pèse le pour et le contre
et qui va choisir celui qui est le
meilleur après un calcul coût avantage
objectifs et informés et bien c'est
précisément ce que vont essayer de
vérifier en 1944 les chercheurs de
l'université de columbia paul lazarsfeld
bernard bérail than he has et le godet
dans leur livre the people's choice of
the world turns out of mind il le place
dans une chambre comme time alors c'est
un livre qui a fait date en sociologie
parce que il l'inaugurent un modèle
d'explication du vote qui resté célèbre
comme le modèle de columbia on s'en
souvient principalement pour deux
résultats différents que moi je vais
traiter dans deux vidéos séparés ils
essayent d'un côté de voir si les
campagnes médiatiques ont un impact sur
les résultats du vote quand est-ce qu'on
arrêtera de nous prendre pour des polos
mais ça c'est ce qu'on verra dans la
prochaine vidéo quelle indignité et ils
veulent également vérifier si les
individus choisissent leur candidat de
manière rationnelle en faisant vraiment
un calcul coût avantage et ça c'est ce
qu'on va voir maintenant mais pour vous
faire une réponse courte
[Musique]
et
alors comment expliquer les choix de
vote des individus le livre analyse
l'élection présidentielle américaine de
1940 qui voit s'opposer le démocrate
franklin delano roosevelt qui reste
aujourd'hui connue pour le new deal
principalement et aussi pour être le
seul président américain avoir fait
trois mandats et de l'autre côté le
républicain howard wilkie qui reste
aujourd'hui connue pour pas grand chose
en fait mise à part d'avoir été un
ancien soutien de roosevelt en 1932 et
d'avoir complètement retourné sa veste
pour rejoindre le parti républicain elle
je n'ai pas pris conscience que cela
allait faire de moi le traite pour
vraiment comprendre l'originalité de
cette enquête il faut s'intéresser un
petit peu à la figure de paul félix
lazarsfeld qui va avoir un rôle majeur
dans le développement des méthodes
quantitatives en sociologie
[Musique]
lazarsfeld c'est un intellectuel
autrichien qui passe un doctorat de
mathématiques à l'université de vienne
mais c'est aussi un militant marxiste
qui étudie beaucoup la science politique
et c'est vraiment important d'avoir en
tête cette double origine disciplinaire
parce que lazarsfeld il va justement
injecté tout son savoir mathématique
dans l'étude des phénomènes sociaux dans
les années 1930 il émigre aux états unis
et en 1940 il est embauché par
l'université de columbia dans laquelle
il fonde le bureau pour la recherche
sociale appliquée dont la première
enquête sera justement the people's
choice cette enquête va être à
l'initiative d'un nouveau modèle
d'organisation de la recherche notamment
parce qu'ils utilisent des outils
innovants pour l'époque comme les
sondages les panels et les analyses
multivariées va y revenir pour finir sur
le personnage lazarsfeld viendra dans
les années 60 le président de
l'association américaine de sociologie
excusez moi du peu et avec son ami et
collègue robert merton ainsi qu'avec le
structuraux fonctionnaliste tels qu'al
personnes ils vont fonder ce que patrick
lehingue appelle la triade impériale qui
domine la sociologie américaine est
justement dans cet équilibre là
lazarsfeld il représente vraiment la
sociologie quantitative triomphante qui
se barre de modèles statistiques et de
méthodes mathématiques toujours plus
complexes il devient alors une espèce
d'entrepreneurs de ces nouvelles
méthodes et le succès est tel qu'il se
retrouve à la tête de ce que le
sociologue michael pollak appelle une
multinationale scientifique qui
conseille des organisations comme la
fondation ford et l'unesco d'un ancien
révolutionnaire autrichien il est donc
devenu le patron d'une véritable
entreprise intellectuelle et l'ironie de
lui échapper d'ailleurs pas hein parce
que il se définissait lui-même comme un
marxiste ont congé son approche
quantitative aura beaucoup d'impact sur
le développement des sciences sociales
mais elle ne séduit pas non plus tous
les sociologues par exemple son ancien
collaborateur charles wright mills il
appelle les méthodes de lazarsfeld une
véritable quant aux frais ni et il lui
reprochera son manque d'imagination
sociologiques comme il le défend
justement dans l'imagination
sociologique dont je vous reparlerai
sûrement en jour
mais je n'ai
un
bon maintenant que les présentations
sont faites revenons à 1940
[Musique]
à ce moment là il ya un petit séisme qui
est en train de se produire dans le
monde des sciences sociales parce que ça
fait tout pile quatre ans que le
statisticien george gallup a inventé le
tout premier sondage d'opinion tels
qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui en 1936 il
a réussi à prévoir la réélection de
roosevelt en se fondant sur un
échantillon représentatif de 50000
personnes c'est impressionnant parce que
au même moment le literary david gest
prédisaient la victoire du républicain
alfred landon à partir d'une enquête
faite sur 10 millions de personnes
cette usine [ __ ] c'est pas rien c'est
pas trois personnes mais même si
l'échantillon du journal étaient 200
fois plus grand que celui de galles up
et se sont tout de même trempé parce
qu'il y avait un énorme biais de
sélection sur lequel je reviendrai plus
tard cela permet donc de consacrer la
méthode galope et met en avant la
nécessité de sélectionner un échantillon
représentatif de la population pour
avoir une mesure fiable de l'opinion
publique et je vous renvoie à la très
bonne vidéo de spleen si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur les sondages
[Musique]
alors l'équipe de lazard feld va suivre
une méthodologie qui à l'époque est une
véritable petite révolution
ils vont faire une étude dans l'est rien
c'est un conte et semi rural semi urbain
de l'état de l'ohio et ils vont tirer au
sort un échantillon de 3000 personnes
qu'ils vont interroger sur tout un tas
de choses comme leur statut social leur
habitude culturelle leurs préférences
politiques et bien sûr leur opinion sur
la campagne présidentielle il faut avoir
en tête que ces interrogatoires ils sont
pas du tout fait comme maintenant au
téléphone ou sur internet avec des
personnes soûles et qui montre une fois
sur deux non non les enquêteurs ils vont
sur place pour récolter les informations
ce qui permet déjà de lever d'éventuels
les ambiguïtés qui pourrait y avoir dans
les questions et au passage ils peuvent
aussi noté un grand nombre de détails
comme le style de décoration le confort
de la maison la présence de livres en
gros toutes sortes de petites
informations et nos graphiques qui vont
être très importantes mais outre la
précision des données la particularité
de ce dispositif c'est que le sondage va
être pas l'elysée ça ça veut dire que le
même questionnaire va être administrés à
sept reprises différentes entre mai et
novembre 1940 auprès d'un noyau dur
d'environ 600 participants le gros
avantage des études par panel c'est que
justement ça permet de voir des
changements d'avis sur les mêmes
personnes et par exemple là ça va
permettre d'évaluer si l'avancé de la
campagne médiatique ça a fait changer
d'opinion publique et peut-être de bord
politique certaines des personnes
interrogées
[Musique]
bon plusieurs résultats importants vont
émerger de cette étude le premier et
c'est peut-être le plus important c'est
avant tout que les gens sont globalement
très peu intéressés par la campagne
électorale
parce que je peux vous dire
oui au oui quand vous voulez dire
quelque chose risi dramatiser on vous
l'a dit et redit mais bon après on vous
laisse en russie a dit ben que que nous
nous qu'on en avait plus ou moins rien à
rien à péter ah bah oui voilà j'allais
dire pareil et l'autre grand résultat
des enquêtes c'est que les choix
électoraux sont fortement corrélés au
contexte social des citoyens et en
particulier leur religion leurs revenus
et leur type d'habitat alors pour
mesurer sa ils divisent leurs
échantillons 5 strates allant de a à d
pour créer la variable statut économique
et social s es avec aaa étant le plus
élevé et des étangs le moins élevé puis
ils vont croiser cette variable avec la
religion catholique ou protestant et
avec le lieu d'habitation rural ou
urbain et ensuite ils ont construit un
indice de prédisposition politiques iep
et paix allant de 1 à 7 en fonction de
ses caractéristiques qu'ils distribuent
du coup comme ça de droite à gauche ou
de tomba le 1 ça représente donc les
individus riches protestants et ruraux
et donc le set représente l'opposé c'est
à dire les individus plutôt pauvre
catholique et urbain et si cet indice
peut paraître à première vue un peu
sommaire et ben en fait il s'avère
hautement prédictif du vote en effet
quand on observe les attitudes de vote
en fonction de l' indice de
prédisposition politique on voit que les
riches protestants et ruraux sont 74% à
voter républicain lawal inverse les
pauvres catholique et urbains sont 83% à
voter démocrate et on voit que c'est
entre le numéro 3 et le numéro 4 de
lundi ce que la bascule se fait c'est ce
qui fera écrire al azhar feld un
individu pense politiquement comme il
est socialement les caractéristiques
sociales détermine les préférences
politiques
du coup ça nous permet de comprendre
pourquoi quatre ans plus tôt le sondage
du literary djs sur dix millions de
personnes s'étaient trompés en fait il
avait interrogé des listes de personnes
qui étaient facilement disponible pour
eux donc ils y avaient leurs propres
lecteurs les propriétaires de voitures
et ceux qui avaient le téléphone ils ont
donc à chaque fois sélectionné des
individus bien plus riche que la moyenne
de la population ce qui explique la
sueur déclarations des votes
républicains par rapport au vote
démocrate et que du coup il est raté la
dynamique de roosevelt est entre
guillemets c'est bien parce que toutes
ces caractéristiques sociales
influencent les comportements de vote
que quand on fait un sondage il faut
respecter les proportions ses
caractéristiques pour avoir un
échantillon représentatif de la
population on peut espérer dire quelque
chose de l'opinion publique l'un des
autres gros point positif de cette étude
c'est que lazarsfeld va introduire des
analyses multivariées ça ça deviendra
d'ailleurs un petit peu sa marque de
fabrique un dans le reste de ses travaux
l'idée c'est d'essayer de hiérarchiser
les variables pour voir quelle est la
variable la plus importante en gros sel
qui va le plus prédire le comportement
électoral par exemple là si on regarde
la probabilité de voter démocrate selon
la religion et le statut social on voit
évidemment que les pauvres et
catholiques sont ceux qui votent le plus
démocrate mais on voit aussi que belle
et riche catholique ils ont toujours
plus de chance de voter démocrate que
les pauvres protestons donc ici c'est
clairement la religion qui influencent
le plus le vote beaucoup plus que le
statut économique et social
[Musique]
alors évidemment ces résultats sont pas
spécifiques aux états unis et en france
le même genre de constat sera mis en
évidence en 1977 dans le livre de guy
michelat et michel simon classe religion
et comportements politiques il confirme
donc le rôle décisif de ce qu'on
appellera en france les variables lourde
du vote à savoir le statut
socioéconomique la religion le genre où
les valeurs alors évidemment
l'influencent de ces variables elle va
changer au cours du temps il faut bien
se rappeler que par nature le savoir
sociologique il est contextuel par
exemple pour le genre le vote féminin
était initialement beaucoup plus à
droite que celui des hommes et
aujourd'hui c'est le contraire parce que
le vote d'extrême droite et
principalement à votre masculin par
exemple si les femmes avaient été les
seuls à voter en 2002 et en 2007 lionel
jospin serait arrivé au second tour est
ségolène royal aurait été élu pour ce
qui est du statut socioéconomique là
aussi pas mal de changements qu'on a
parfois un peu trop vite analysé comme
la fin du vote de classe notamment parce
que 70 % des ouvriers voter à gauche en
1978 et qu'ils ne sont plus que 38 % en
2007 en fait il semblerait plutôt qu'on
assiste à une métamorphose qui a une fin
du vote de classe parce que le statut
socioprofessionnel reste toujours un
critère assez déterminant du vote en
particulier aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
par exemple que la variable patrimoine
et celle qui détermine bien plus que le
revenu les chances de voter à droite
[Musique]
pour conclure malgré ses nombreuses
transformations de la société le modèle
explicatif entamée par lazarsfeld en
1944 continue d'être pertinent pour
comprendre nos comportements électoraux
actuelle c'est notamment ce qu'ont mis
en évidence pour la présidentielle de
2017 les sociologues cécile braconniers
baptiste coulmont et jean yves dormagen
dans leur article toujours pas de
chrysanthèmes pour les variables lourds
de la participation électorale dans
lequel il pointe que les inégalités
socio démographiques de la participation
n'ont fait que s'accroître au cours de
la dernière décennie et qu'elles sont en
premier lieu la conséquence des
inégalités de scolarisation mais ça on y
reviendra dans un autre épisode c'est
tout pour cette première partie sur le
modèle de columbia je reviendrai dans
une prochaine vidéo sur la question de
l'influencé des médias sur nos choix
électoraux en attendant si vous voulez
aller plus loin je vous conseille
chaudement le livre le vote de patrick
lehingue duquel je me suis beaucoup
appuyé pour écrire cette vidéo et c'est
clairement l'un des bilans les plus
complets qu'on puisse trouver à ce jour
sur la sociologie du vote n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner de partager la vidéo si
elle vous a plu je vous rappelle que mon
livre est sorti la semaine dernière et
qu'il est disponible partout moi je vous
fais de gros bisous et à la prochaine
ciao
[Musique]